[موسيقى]
الطعام في سنغافوره ليس كما في غيرها من
البلدان جميع مطابخ العالم تقريبا
تستطيعون تذوقها هنا المطبخ الهندي
والصيني والماليزي والاوروبي كلها في مكان
واحد
تاريخ سنغافوره حافر بالمهاجرين ما يقرب
من نصف السكان البالغ عددهم نحو خمسه
ملايين ونصف المليون هم من الاجانب
الوافدين اليها للعمل او الدراسه او
السياحه وهي واحده من اكثر دول العالم
كثافه سكانيه
سنغافوره توصف بانها مطعم كبير الطعام هنا
متنوع بشده يمكن للزائرين الاختيار من
قائمه طويله لا تنتهي من الضفادع المقليه
الى الاطعمه البحريه او الماكولات الحلال
حسب الشريعه الاسلاميه
هي ارض المهاجرين نحن جميعا احفاد مهاجرين
من اسيا وهذه الاصول المختلفه هي اساس
المطبخ السنغافوري وقد سمح ذلك بظهور
انماط مختلفه تطفي كل واحده منها خصوصيه
على نكهات اطباق سنغافوره وان سالتني ان
كان هناك طبق مميز عليك تجربته في
سنغافوره فسوف اقول لك عليك تجربه
السلطعون مع الفلفل الحار
بالنسبه لمعظم السنغافوري يتم تناول
وجبتين من كل ثلاث وجبات يوميا خارج
المنزل لهذا فان التجاره المتعلقه
بالمطاعم ووجبات الشارع ضخمه للغايه
جئنا الى هنا لتجربه الحياه المحليه
الاصيله لان السنغافوره مكان تجتمع فيه
الثقافه الاسيويه والثقافه الغربيه معا
ولهذا فان اطعمه الثقافات تمتزج انه مكان
فريد من نوعه النكهه نموذجيه للغايه في
جنوب اسيا
هنا تغلق بعض الشوارع في الساعه السابعه
مساء امام حركه المرور حيث تزدحم بالسياح
الذين حضروا لتجربه وجبات جديده لا
يستطيعون الحصول عليها في بلادهم وللتلبيه
الطلب المتزايد على النكهات والمذاقات
الفريده فان بعض المطاعم ترصد مبالغ كبيره
استقطاب الطاهات المهره من جميع انحاء
العالم
الشيف جاستن كويك واحد من هؤلاء الطاهات
الذين درسوا من الطبخ في فرنسا ثم استقر
به الحال في سنغافوره لامتاع زبائنه
في طعام الشارع يفضلون صنع سرطان البحر
بصلصه الفلفل هل تسالني عن مفهوم المطعم
المفهوم ببساطه هو ان ياتي الناس للحصول
على افضل ما يستطيعون الحصول عليه
تناول الطعام في سنغافوره هو النشاط
الاجتماعي الرئيسي للسكان والسياح وعلى
طاوله الطعام قد تتخذ العديد من القرارات
المصيريه سواء المتعلقه بالعمل ام بالحياه
العامه
[موسيقى]